[Musique]
entre montmartre et pigalle la rue des
martyrs aux 80 de celle ci le cabaret mi
chou en quelques années le maître des
lieux véritable capitaine d'un navire
nommé désir a fait de cet endroit au
lieu des nuits parisiennes
chaque soir où il fut accueilli par les
applaudissements chaleureux d'un public
nombreux qui a souvent réservé sa place
plusieurs semaines à l'avant ce parcours
réussi pour cet amiénois du quartier
populaire de la gare autodidacte
ambitieux qui a débuté très jeune par
les petits boulots je suis rentré comme
plongeur dans un restaurant et mia le le
picardia et j'étais groom au grand hôtel
aussi m et après alors la presse et le
dernier travail de réchauffer hennium
cela m'amusait beaucoup plus il tombe en
plein air en liberté avec mon petit vélo
je vendais les journaux dans mean alors
rejeté la demande et paris presses
l'intransigeant puis j'ai voulu
découvrir paris
vers 23 heures après le dîner dans une
ambiance volontairement surchauffé le
spectacle débute la prochaine de
serveurs se transforme en troupes de
choc baptisé les miches est la fête
commence burlesque et bouffonne un
véritable mardi gras à dérider les plus
coincés des spectateurs les travestis
défilé professionnalisme oblige on s'y
perd dans ses imitations de jeanne mas
madonna dalida et autres artistes
n'échoue est un nom bien connu des
noctambules parisiens et il n'est pas
rare de rencontrer ici des têtes connues
tels yves mourousi mireille mathieu et
bien d'autres personnalités
si la réputation de son cabaret n'est
plus à faire nichons reste pourtant très
présents et là tous les soirs ou presque
pour superviser les événements et
présente régulièrement
finalement spectacle messieurs surnom
qui ne laisse pas de doute sur les
tendances affective maître de ces lieux
ici les observe aussi une caissière
permet à venir il ya une vieille je vous
ai dit qu'avec vestiaires et une
caissière et y avait aussi notamment
cuisine etc et vous voyez on est enfant
n'est pas mise
on aime bien les petites femmes et se
faire une confidence
moi personnellement j'aime tellement les
femmes que j'ai touche pas les abîmer
soutenez dans une ambiance légère niche
où ce véritable gémeaux qui refuse de
dire son âge cache un autre personnage
sensible et généreux loin les frivolités
c'est ainsi qu'une fois par mois ils
invitent gratuitement à des jeunes et je
suis 3e âge de nos marques
quant à sa mère qui habite toujours
amiens il lui rend visite presque une
fois par semaine
fier d'être aux picards né sous le fait
savoir jusqu'au money de son cabaret qui
affiche chaque soir le célèbre pas
régional la flamiche plus tarder
quoi
[Musique]